그때 한창 올라갔을 때 금리가 막
6%, 7% 그 이상 받는 경우도
있었거든요. 그래서이 모든게 어떻게
보면 저는 돈을 너무 많이 풀었어요.
6억까지밖에 대출 안 해 주겠다라고
해 가지고 실질적으로 주택을 사기에는
좀 쉽지 않은 그런 시장이 됐습니다.
원화 가치는 앞으로 저는 더 많이
떨어질 것 같아요. 그 원화를 지키기
위해서는.
[음악]
>> 네. 네, 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다.
지금 시기가 코로나 때 시기랑 좀
비슷한 부분이 있거든요. 코로나 때
어떤 부분이 좀 비슷했고 앞으로
코로나 때를 참고해서 어떤 방식으로
투자하면 좋을지 오늘 영상으로 촬영해
보도록 하겠습니다. 우선 코로나 때
금리가 갑자기 급속도로 내려갔고 제로
금리가 됐습니다. 엄청 많은 돈을
풀기 시작했고 미국뿐만 아니라 한국도
굉장히 많은 돈을 풀었어요. 근데
지금 시기도 돈을 굉장히 많이 풀고
있습니다. 그래서 작년 같은 경우에는
우리나라 같은 경우에는 RP 매입을
100조 이상 했어요. 100조
이상을 한 거는 저는 처음 봤습니다.
2008년도에 저희가 금융이기 때도
한 18조 정도 풀었는데 작년에는
무려 100조나 풀었고 그리고 앞으로
돈을 뭐 정책 지연금 해 가지고 약
30조원 정도 더 푼다 그러죠. 지금
돈을 굉장히 많이 풀고 있습니다.
지금 코로나 때와 비슷한 양상으로 좀
흘러가고 있다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
그리고 금리도 코로나 때 이제 많이
내려갔는데 지금도 또 많이
내려갔잖아요. 그래서 2022년
하반기 때 급속도로 오르기 시작했다가
지금 금리가 많이 내려가고 있습니다.
어, 뭐 빌딩 담보 대출 기준으로 좀
설명드리면 그때 한창 올라갔을 때
금리가 막 6% 7% 그 이상 받는
경우도 있었거든요. 근데 요즘에는 좀
많이 내려와서 법인 재무 재표만
괜찮다라고 하면은 지금 3%뿐만
아니라 2% 대도 실제로 좀 많이
나오고 있습니다. 금리가 좀 많이
내려갔다라고 보시면 될 거 같고.
그리고 주택 시세도 그때 우리 코로나
때 생각해 보면 진짜 똑같았어요.
지금이랑 계속 막 매주 최고가
경신했다 뜨고 그때 당시에는 막
아크로 리버파크 막 최고가 찍었다라고
해서 기사가 계속 뜨고 진짜 주택
가격이 천정부지로 오르기
시작했습니다. 그리고 지금시기 같은
경우에도 뭐 이미 언론에도 많이
나왔지만 지금 서울 주택 가격
상승률이 굉장히 높아요. 지금 어떻게
보면은 코로나 때랑 지금 그 주택
가격이랑 이런게 좀 비슷한 부분이
있습니다. 부동산 시장 반응도
초저금리랑 유동성이랑 같이 풀리다
보니까 그런 돈들이 지금 주택뿐만
아니라 건물 시장에도 많이
들어왔어요. 그래서 실제로 제가
코로나 때 스터디 할 때도 수강생분
중에 한 6, 70%는 다 아파트
투자자분들이 많았거든요. 그래서 지금
같은 경우에도 주택 투자 하기가 좀
쉽지 않잖아요. 그래서 최근에는
규제로 인해서 다주택자들은 추가로
주택을 살 수 없게 돼서이 주택
투자자분들이 1등 시장으로 좀 많이
넘어올 것으로 예상이 됩니다. 그리고
그때는 그 15억 초과되는 주택은
대출이 좀 안 나왔잖아요. 근데
우리가 이번에 발표한 것도
6억까지밖에 대출 안 해 주겠다라고
해 가지고 실질적으로 주택을 사기에는
좀 쉽지 않은 그런 시장이 됐습니다.
그리고 코로나 때 여러분들 생각해
보면 주택 가격뿐만 아니라 주식도
정말 화랑이었어요. 그리고 코인
시장도 워낙 좋았습니다. 근데
여러분들 지금도 보시면은 주식도
이번에 3천 넘었죠. 그리고 코인도
가격 오르고 있죠. 주택 가격도 이제
계속 오르죠. 어떻게 보면 지금
코로나 때와 좀 비슷한 양상을 보이지
않나 그렇게 생각을 합니다. 그리고
원화 가치는 계속 떨어지고 있어요.
그래서 그때 코로나 때도 환율이 한
1,300원 정도 됐습니다. 그리고
지금도 뭐 1,360원 정도 되는데
이것도 원래 이제 작년 말까지는 뭐
1,400원 넘었잖아요. 국민
연금이랑 이런 거가 이제 좀 개입을
하면서 많이 좀 낮춰지고 있긴 한데
아무래도 지금 뭐 원화 가치의 약세는
계속 이어지고 있습니다. 그리고 지금
정부 정책 기조도 좀 이렇게 돈을
많이 풀려고 합니다. 코로나 때도
워낙 경기가 안 좋다 보니까 돈을
많이 풀었고 그리고 지금 같은
경우에도 경기가 많이 안 좋다 보니까
좀 돈을 많이 푸는 경향이 있습니다.
근데 한 가지 보셔야 될게 그래도 그
코로나 때만 해도 임대가 좀 잘되긴
했었거든요. 지금 시기는 임대 시장이
그렇게 좋지 않습니다. 그래서 작년
같은 경우에는 폐업자 수가 100만
명이 넘었잖아요. 그래서 그 정도로
지금 자영업자분들의 상황이 좋지
않습니다. 물론 이제 이번에 돈을
풀면서 잠깐 좋아질 거라고 좀 예상은
들지만 좀 장기적인 시점에 봤을 때는
코로나 때보다는 그렇게 화랑일 거
같지 않습니다. 그래서 앞으로
공실이나 뭐 임대료 올라가는 수준은
뭐 드라마틱하게 올라갈 거라고 생각은
하진 않고 뭐 성수동 연무장길이라든지
아니면 뭐 명동이라든지 아니면은 저기
앞구정 로데오라든지 이런 메인길에
있는 빌딩 같은 경우에는 임대료
가격이 계속 올라갈 것으로 저는
예상이 됩니다. 그래서이 모든게
어떻게 보면 저는 돈을 너무 많이
풀었어요. 그게 다 이런 자산 그니까
부동산으로 흘러 들어갈 수밖에
없거든요. 저는 작년보다는 그래도
빌딩 가격이 좀 오를 것이라고 좀
조심스럽게 예상을 해 봅니다. 그래서
제가 봤을 때는 원화를 가지고 있는게
제일 리스크인 거 같습니다. 그래서
차라리 그냥 달러로 바꿔 놓거나
아니면 뭔가 그냥 자산에 투자를 해
놓던지 그렇게 좀 바꿔 놔야 되는데
원화 가치는 앞으로 저는 더 많이
떨어질 것 같아요. 그 원화를 지키기
위해서는 다른 투자 방향으로 좀 바꿔
놓으시는 거를 좀 저는 권해드립니다.
그래서 여러분들 어 지금 어떻게 보면
금리도 좀 많이 내려가고 좋아지면서
최근에 빌딩 시장으로 좀 관심이
많아졌는데 근데 이런 부분을 좀
참고해 가지고 진짜 확실한 거만
사셔야 됩니다. 진짜 대자뷰처럼
코로나 때와 좀 비슷한 양상을 보이고
있는데 어 제가 말씀드렸던 그런 지금
임대 시장은 빠른 실내 좋아질 거라고
생각은 하지 않기 때문에 좀 이런
부분을 좀 참고하셔 가지고 빌딩
투자하는데 도움이 되셨으면
좋겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다.
[음악]